hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my big preview for agents of
shield season 2 everything's coming back
next week so this is like the week to
get ready to cast a bunch of big
characters from the comics and they will
be doing a big crossover with Avengers 2
whenever it comes out next spring so
I'll just start by explaining the new
art of season 2 then two new characters
and then explain what's going on with
all the crossovers and hello it's any
new people if you're just finding me for
the first time I'm doing agents of
shield and Marvel videos all season long
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm even gonna be doing like a special
swag giveaway I'll explain at the end of
this so right off the bat just careful
for spoilers from the finale from season
1 I'm gonna have to explain season 2
using season 1 so I'll wait just a sec
ok everybody ready here we go there will
be a time gap between the end of season
1 in the beginning of season 2 about six
months Skye is now in full on agent mode
Coulson has been director of shield this
whole time and Hydra Ward is still in a
holding cell he's still a part of the
show he'll just be like the Loki of the
season like the bad boy they stick in
the holding cell whenever they don't
need him for a special mission and oh
yes they will definitely be letting him
out for special missions this year they
did it with Loki and dark world they're
gonna do it with Ward I love that he
grew a beard just to let you know he's
extra bad like motorcycle-riding
chain-smoking bad I'm totally just
kidding I totally loved what they did
with the character in the last couple of
episodes in season 1 I did not like
quarterback Ward but I totally loved
Hydra Ward
see this this is why you stick with the
show they had a plan all along so that's
a lesson if there's any characters that
you totally don't dig right now
something crazy might happen at the end
of the season and they might start being
really awesome right now there are a
couple big arcs they've already teed up
for episode 1 there's all the Kree code
I'm calling it Creed right now there's
also slim chance it could be Inhumans
related feel free to suggest alternative
so if you think you've figured it out
that's gonna be Skye's Standing Order in
between regular missions decode the
symbols so obviously the other big
running plot is gonna be cleaning up the
remainders of Hydra they also just aired
the first two minutes of that first
episode and they tease this Indiana
Jones type warehouse full of unknown
items so that also is gonna be one of
the running plots so you may have heard
about some of the new characters
obviously the biggest one is Lucy
Lawless she's basically playing agent
Hartley she's not a character from
comics she's someone totally new to the
show there's also a bunch of dollhouse
Whedon versed people joining the cast as
new characters who aren't from the
comics but there are a few big comic
book characters Lucy Lawless is playing
what's being described as veteran agent
Hartley so she's gonna be someone
Coulson goes to for help but being Lucy
Lawless you can totally expect her to be
a badass I think the only show I ever
saw her on where she was not a little
bit scary was Parks and Rec who she also
happened to be on with star-lord
how's that for a Marvel verse crossover
the biggest new character from the
comics though is gonna be Mockingbird
she's being played by Adrianne Palicki
if you haven't read the comics recently
she had a big part in the secret
Avengers storyline with Hawkeye that all
went down after the Civil War event as a
character she does have a few special
abilities she was injected with some
Super Soldier serum that slowed down the
aging process made her super strong I
don't know if the show's gonna play with
that think of it as like a lesser
version of what happened to Captain
America
she's also this super-smart biochemist
so think of her as being like May and
Simmons combined season 2 is actually
gonna feature a lot of new badass women
which I'm sure they will totally use for
comedy when some of the bigger dudes
like Triplett and ward or on-screen with
them then we have our first big dawn
it's gonna be Kraken from the comic
books he's being played by Daniel
Whitehall who you might recognize from
dollhouse or you know other Joss Whedon
whatnot he might not be the big bad but
he's going to be one of the bigger
villains in the comics he's this
legendary Hydra agent who has this
special helmet that works kind of like
Iron Man armor whenever he puts it on
he's encased in hyper-advanced armor and
the helmet itself works a little bit
like the helmet of fate which I know is
kind of mixing metaphors with DC it just
imbues some of its own personality onto
whoever wears it yeah the really big
character that they've cast is gonna be
Skye's father we don't know if he's
gonna be a villain or if he's gonna be
good he's being played by Col McLaughlin
we don't know really anything about that
character other than he's just a little
bit sinister it looked kinda like he was
covered in blood during the finale last
year if you ever watched him on How I
Met Your Mother
think of it as being like the scary face
captain I'm also really hoping they work
in some trippy twin peaks' references I
feel like it should be illegal to cast
Kyle MacLachlan in some sort of sci-fi
comic book show without doing some twin
peaks' references the last big character
they've announced is Nick blood being
played by Lance hunt
he's gonna be a non-friendly that Colson
goes to for help he's not a comic-book
character but he does lead strike which
is like a British shield type
organization the acronym stands for
special tactical reserve for
international key emergencies pretty
much everybody that is still alive from
season one is also coming back like
Triplett is gonna be a big character on
the team and ward is still totally
around patton oswalt
is also gonna continue to show up on
occasion I'm still totally thinking of
him as like a life model decoy either
that or he had some mystery twin that he
just never talked about they still have
a ton of episodes to shoot so they're
gonna bring on more comic book
characters they just haven't announced
them yet what's happening with the
Avengers 2 crossover is that basically
some of the characters from shield will
be in that movie like Coulson for
instance it'll be somewhat similar to
the time with Winter Soldier where some
of the plot from age of Ultron will be
followed up on in a shield episode the
other really cool thing that's happening
in the premiere next week is we're gonna
have Hayley Atwell and the Howling
Commandos in a flashback scene I will be
doing more videos for that show whenever
it gets closer to the premiere it's not
gonna start airing until shield goes on
break sometime in January but agent
Carter whenever it does come on we'll be
in the same timeslot on the same day
that show just cast the character that
Tony Stark's Jarvis AI is based on his
name is James D'Arcy and he's from
broadchurch if you ever watch that show
the character's name is gonna be Edwin
Jarvis in the cannon how it's gonna work
is he'll be Howard Starks real-life
Butler that Tony Stark
later immortalizes by turning into his
AI then obviously eventually he'll be
turned into the vision during age of
Ultron or at least the vision will be
based on the Jarvis AI it's just like
Iron Man 2 in Captain America where they
had two different actors playing Howard
Stark you know one when he was really
old and one when he's really young I
know it's all totally bleeding together
in our heads but it'll totally be fine
so here are the important dates for the
premiere you need to remember agents of
shield will premiere next Tuesday at 9
p.m. on ABC that's one hour later than
last year so the time changed a little
bit I know that Fox will air the
episodes in Asian countries in the UK
it's on on channel 4 for other countries
just check your local listings and I
don't know when international episodes
are airing but you might have to wait a
week after it airs in the United States
so if you
watch it when it first stairs you might
have to find an alternate way because
shield episodes and flash episodes air
on the same night it's gonna cause a
little bit of a traffic jam with my
video so this is how it's gonna work the
flash airs before shield does so I'll be
doing those videos first those will go
up on Tuesday night's shield videos will
probably just go up Wednesday mornings
the next morning next week is gonna be a
little bit different just because I've
already seen the first episode of the
flash I'll be posting that video early
so I will be posting my shield episode 1
review Tuesday night be sure to
subscribe to get it
it's gonna be a lot of fun I'll also be
live tweeting while it's on TV so all my
social links are in the description I'm
pretty good about not being spoilery
it's just a fun way to talk to people
during the broadcast like while it's
happening in the moment the giveaway
that I'm gonna be doing for all these
comic book shows is just a little bit
different I'll just be randomly
selecting people from the comments who I
just think are really awesome not the
comments that people making in the
comments so if you want me to know that
you're alive just leave comments so
right now click here to get my
non-spoilery review of the first episode
of Gotham that's also coming next week
and click here to learn all about the
new live-action Teen Titans show that's
coming thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you